Yeah.
Hey, I was stuck inside that graver. Long time.
Didn't think I'm making through those long nights,
but you never let you always on time.
Remember when you got me all day, you got me out that,
and now I see your blessing, your blessings every day.
Thankful kingdoms.
I'll never get used to this. I'll never get used to this.
This is how I wanna live.
Be singing about the grave that I'm alive
Now.
Told the devil, you outta Time now
I die.
Die.
I never gave to this. I never get used to this.
This is how I wanna live. Singing live
From the Morning to the evening.
I can sing your praise all day from the
to the
I can soon. Thank
You, Jesus.
I'll never get used to this. I'll never get used to this.
This is how I wanna live
used to this.